hey theo this is crossfire joni up in
southern california
and i just want to tell you i just love
your show you're doing a great job
thank you so much i have a question for
you
i'm just getting over cancer and um
my hair is gone thank you for calling in
crossfire joanie
and uh and i'm sorry that you have
cancer you know i haven't had it but i'm
sure i'll probably have it
and cancer you know
cancer is it's that ninth reindeer or
whatever
you know and that [ __ ] is a gangster uh
let's hear more i'm i'm starting to grow
back but it's still gone
and i'm wondering what do you think do
you think i should wear a hat
or do you think i should just go all
natural okay let me back it up again
it's starting to grow back but i'm just
getting over cancer
and um my hair is gone
i'm starting to grow black but it's
still gone yeah hair don't like cancer
if you have cancer your hair will leave
you know and that's age old that's a you
know
that's the cat chasing his tail right
there let's hear more
and i'm wondering what do you think do
you think i should wear a hat
or do you think i should just go all
natural you think
um someone to get your opinion on that
all natural or
a hat or a scarf or something like that
oh baby girl you got to get a little
get your little hat get your little
crown get your little crown baby
wake up with the king mama get that bk
get that bk head piece get you a whopper
and get that free
hat deuce you know what i'm saying you
could do something beautiful on your
head i think
enjoy it embrace that beautiful little
bald top
you know and you can even flirt with the
guys say hey the curtains match the
drapes you know
and then like you don't have any hair
and you'll be like gang gang
so i think there's some real uh
opportunity there but y'all say get you
a beautiful little hat get your little
uh
you know get you that freaking little
scalp cardigan or something
get you one of them little jewish hats
that little you know that little hair
wallet that they wear
get you six or seven of them stack them
[ __ ] up lily pads your whole damn
head up
but i think yeah be magical
you know get a damn edible hat you
talking to somebody it's going well you
break them off a day you know
30 calories of your cap man it's
something that's beautiful
but i think those are some things you
could do but i think you embrace it um
and it sounds like you already are i
think it's
you know i think it's sweet that you
even asked me
i think it's brave you know i think it's
brave of you
and you could also grow that skull it
you could grow that skull
and that's when you're going out of
business in the front but you still
partying in the back get that hang time
off the back that gang plank
um what else could you do some cute
barrettes maybe
get you a couple barrettes little
canaries or something um
you could do some ear piercings that
could be fun
but you know it puts it in perspective
because i'm always worried about my hair
and i'm worried about how i look and i'm
worried about this and that
and here you are you know you can't you
can't even bring uh
hair to the show right now but you still
showing up
and that's cool you know you could do
the key mullet where you got that chemo
but a little bit of mullet out the back
um but i see i say be just as brave as
you have been in defeating cancer i say
you'd be just as brave
and sprouting something beautiful up top
and have fun with it because you just
even you calling and asking this is uh
is inspiring because you're just making
me you're making everybody that's
listening right now realize man what am
i worried about
you know what am i worried about i'm
worried about how i look if my if my
you know with my leggings match my neck
brace or whatever
if you were in an accident or something
after a you know
cardio class or whatever
and the truth is that you know we got
little ladies out here beating cancer
and you know just saying hey do i go hat
or no hat
yeah here's what i say put a damn nipple
on the top of your head and
break out that third titty tell them
it's that third titty baby
but i think you're beautiful for calling
and i and and just thank you for
brightening my day by sharing your
experience
you know because you share your
experience and your strength and your
hope right there
all in one and that's pretty remarkable
i feel
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah